everybody say hi again and
he's big boy
hi i can't have you up here good boy hey
everyone bandit here i was researching
some stuff about zelda and nintendo for
a larger project that i have planned for
the channel well larger in terms of
production quality anyway and
inadvertently i stumbled across some of
the big n's history some
less than favorable parts of nintendo's
history that is and i just want to put
out there real quick first and foremost
that in this video i am going to be
covering a topic or tube that's a little
bit more mature than what i normally
cover on the channel so if you happen to
have some little humans around just be
mindful of it anyway these controversial
pieces of nintendo history were rather
shocking to me the masked and abandoned
so i decided why not share it with all
of you and real quick before we get into
the video i'd like to make a wager with
you that you can participate in if you
would like to kind of like what i did
with my ganondorf facts video a little
bit earlier on if you learn one new
thing when you watch this video you have
to leave a like down below and if you
learn at least three or more things you
have to subscribe to the channel which i
highly doubt that you will regret either
way but on the flip side if you learn
absolutely nothing about nintendo from
the contents of this video then let me
know in a comment below and i will come
down there and like that comment
personally let's have a virtual shake on
it
i'm just going to assume that you're
doing the hand at
let's get into the list
number one the company that made donkey
kong sued nintendo and no you did not
hear that incorrectly i said the company
that made donkey kong but let me explain
what i mean by that and you might want
to buckle up because this one gets a
little bit complicated when you credit a
company with making a product especially
in the entertainment industry that
encompasses a lot of moving pieces like
design or build in this case nintendo or
more specifically shigeru miyamoto
himself did indeed make donkey kong in
that he conceptualized and designed the
smash hit game that was responsible for
putting nintendo on the map but he did
not build it the actual work for coding
the game and making it come to life was
contracted out to another technology
company that went by the name of ikegami
tsushiniki kikami was hired by nintendo
to build donkey kong from the ground up
and once they were finished with the
game ikigami then provided nintendo with
a certain number of circuit boards that
were complete with the game installed on
the board but they themselves retained
the only copy of the game's actual
source code only giving nintendo the
finished products when donkey kong
became the smash hit worldwide that we
all know it did nintendo duplicated
copies of these circuit boards of donkey
kong apparently without ikagami's
knowledge and they didn't give them
permission to do that beforehand on top
of that when nintendo inevitably decided
to come out with donkey kong's sequel
donkey kong jr they built the second
game off of the original source code
knowing that ikagami was the only
company that had the source code
nintendo instead hired somebody else to
reverse engineer the game and therefore
deduce the source code according to a
1983 article from the japanese gaming
magazine called game machine when
ikagami heard nintendo was replicating
circuit boards and reverse engineering
the game they took it straight to court
but nintendo sued them right back
claiming that there were no royalties
discussed in the original deal and that
the work that had been delivered to them
in the form of the game donkey kong had
been paid for completely they also had a
one-up if you will on the situation
since the game donkey kong had
nintendo's copyright logo in the game
and not ikigami's number second the
playstation was very briefly a nintendo
console in the early 90s and after lots
of success in the 80s following the
releases of donkey kong super smash
brothers the legend of zelda super
metroid and their home consoles like the
famicom and the super nintendo
entertainment system nintendo was
looking to partner up with an
electronics company in order to take all
this stuff to the next level and create
an add-on to the snes that would enable
larger games to be developed for the
system the trick was that the new add-on
would use interactive optical disks
called compact disc interactables or
philips cdi for short and if that name
rings a bell it's probably because
you've had nightmares of the zelda cdi
games
anyway so the story goes that nintendo
and sony were the best of friends really
with sony even being responsible for
developing the sound chips for the super
famicon system while the two mega
companies were working together to
develop the aforementioned cdi add-on
for the snes all was going well and
according to plan at the consumer
electronics show in 1991 sony proudly
unveiled their new add-on to the snes
called the snes
cd or the nintendo play station one day
later nintendo revealed that they
decided to break ties with sony and
instead decided to go with phillips
directly for the production of this
add-on to the snes sony's president at
the time a man named norio oga was quite
upset at this highly visible extremely
embarrassing turn of events and then
appointed ken kutaragi as the lead
developer for sony's playstation console
with one specific goal in mind
b nintendo's rival the playstation
released as a standalone console in the
90s and competed directly with
nintendo's brand new nintendo 64 with
the former selling over 100 million
units to date and the latter selling
about 32 million in addition to that
nintendo's controversial new
relationship with phillips directly
resulted in the creation of the zelda
cdi game so
you tell me who won that one number
tress the virtual boy was not supposed
to release when or how it did if you're
cocking your head to the side right now
go on a virtual boy what the heck allow
me to explain the virtual boy console
was nintendo's first attempt at virtual
reality gaming and released in 1995. it
was infamously a commercial failure i
mean they told news articles that it
would sell 14 million copies in two
years and before they pulled the plug on
it prematurely it had managed to sell
about 770 thousand
yeah it was named the virtual boy
because it was developed by gunpei yokoi
the man responsible for creating the
game boy which was a commercial success
story goes that yokoi had largely been
left alone to develop the virtual boy
with little to no input or oversight
from nintendo's current big dog of video
games shigeru miyamoto apparently
nintendo released the virtual boy way
too early and directly against yokoy's
wishes who said that he would have never
released it in its released state
eventually it was revealed that they did
this so that they could focus the
development resources that were on the
virtual boy to the nintendo 64 which
they were currently trying to push
production on this may have actually
been because of the whole playstation
situation which had released in 1994 and
which the nintendo 64 was supposed to
directly compete against to make matters
worse after 31 years of faithful service
to the company the legendary mr yokoi
retired in his 50s apparently
voluntarily and conveniently right after
the disaster of the virtual boy which
nintendo insists was not because of the
virtual boy personally though
i think there might be a little
something more to that story since
immediately after leaving nintendo he
went on and started another game company
called koto and then died one year later
in the year 1997. number delta you have
the japanese yakuza to thank for your
video games nintendo as a company was
born in the year 1889 you know a few
years before video games were on the
market their first and only products
were playing cards like physical playing
cards which were bought for the purposes
of gambling however in 1907 the
government of japan banned all forms of
gambling under the new at the time penal
code
chapter 23. so all of a sudden nobody
was buying nintendo's playing cards
which was their one and only thing that
they made so their days were over and
they had to scramble to find something
else to make right
nope they still made cards but they just
manufactured a different kind of card
called hanafuda which was not outlawed
because hanafuda cards did not have
numbers on them but how do you gamble
with cards that don't have numbers on
them right well yakuza certainly figured
it out and they wanted those cards lots
of them and as the yakuza hanafuda
connection became more and more obvious
to the entire country of japan all of
the rival hanafuda card production
companies shut down production because
they didn't want to be associated with
you know organized crime but nintendo
didn't really mind and so it was that
nintendo became one of the only
companies to continually produce
hanafuda cards which were almost
exclusively purchased by the yakuzab for
the purposes of illegal gambling on the
plus side nintendo made a lot of money
off of all of this and was brought out
of otherwise shore death they rode all
this money off the yakuza business all
the way until the 1960s when they
decided to get into some
other forms of entertainment which
brings me to the final point number v
i don't even have a crafty title for
this nintendo made love hotels
you know hotels that uh couples go to so
that they can
[Music]
love not even joking in the 60s after
the boom of the hanafuda card business
had begun to dwindle the current
president of nintendo at the time a man
by the name of hiroshi yamochi saw an
opportunity in the booming business
potential of love hotels which were and
are not illegal in japan by the way
apparently there were even talks between
nintendo and the heads of the yakuza
about incorporating prostitution into
their love hotels which was illegal but
nothing ever came of these talks as
around this time in 1966 a certain 25
year old maintenance engineer named
gunpei yokoi was noticed developing what
would soon become a hit child's play toy
called the ultra hand and since then the
company has focused exclusively on
creating entertainment in a more family
friendly way
as opposed to a family creating way
and that's the list how did you do did
you learn one new thing be sure to leave
a like below on this video did you learn
at least three new things it would be an
honor to me if you would subscribe to
the channel did you learn nothing at all
well head on down to the comments below
and let me know and i'll be sure to come
down there and give it a like you can
still like or subscribe though it's not
exclusive to the deal you won't regret
it anyway as always thank you so much
for watching and a huge thanks of course
to my fabulous bandit crew of which i
have some new names to announce please
say hello to moon and brent j pascal
hatter and where's the lamb sauce thank
you guys so much for joining up and to
you watching if you are interested in
helping these videos get made and
helping me to eat food and stuff like
that feel free to click on that join
button located below any of my videos or
follow the links in the description
below for my patreon and merch pages
also down there are the links to my
social media pages so come follow me for
more little random facts and spicy takes
and whatever the heck i feel like
tweeting oh and i had one more thing to
talk about before i end the video as
some of you know i went live with my
let's play channel this week and things
have been going great thank you so much
to those of you who have stopped by or
even subscribed to bandit plays and to
those of you who are curious about what
that is i'll link to it in the
description below so you can check it
out yourself but i just wanted to take a
moment real quick and thank a good
friend of mine who was very instrumental
in helping me go live with bandit plays
this isn't sponsored or anything i just
felt like giving him some thanks his
name is art of joe and he runs a web
comic called charming and let me tell
you
it's charming alright if you like witty
or punny humor like i do especially the
kind that's based off of like fairy
tales and stuff you know kind of like uh
the shrek movies you will love this web
comic it is hysterical i've not been
disappointed in a single chapter yet
i'll link to it in the description below
as well and on his behalf thank you so
much in advance for checking that out i
think that's all i've got for you in
this one so as always i hope you have a
wonderful rest of your day this is
massington abandoned looking forward to
seeing you in the next one and signing
out
[Music]
you